curiosamente a pesar de que angela
merkel continúa teniendo un alto grado
de popularidad aquí en el país su
presencia es uno de los factores que
sinceramente afectó a armin la 7 en su
carrera por suceder a merkel a armin la
7 estuvo prácticamente a la sombra de
merkel durante buena parte de la campaña
y esto sin duda afectó a los
conservadores es algo que se conoce como
el bono de la persona que está a cargo
en el país otra elemento que explica por
qué los conservadores sufrieron bastante
tiene que ver con el desempeño propio de
armin la chet que cometió bastantes
errores durante la campaña política en
alemania uno de ellos muy recordado en
julio durante las inundaciones graves en
el occidente del país cuando se le vio
riéndose en medio del desastre todo esto
hizo que su popularidad y su
credibilidad sobre todo se viera
afectado en momentos en que los alemanes
indecisos sobre qué camino escoger tras
16 años de merkel estaban buscando
precisamente un candidato que les diera
estabilidad y que les diera un camino
seguro para esta nueva etapa en alemania
pasemos ahora a hablar del punto que
centra toda la atención qué tan difícil
y largo puede ser el proceso para formar
las coaliciones de gobierno se lograría
el objetivo de conformar un nuevo
ejecutivo antes de navidad'
por eso es por lo menos el objetivo que
tienen los diferentes partidos
principales pero el camino puede ser muy
largo y muy difícil solamente en 2017
para darles un ejemplo la búsqueda de
una coalición duró cinco meses y el país
ahora está más dividido y el panorama
político ahora está mucho más
fragmentado así que los expertos
aseguran que el camino de verdad puede
ser muy difícil la llave de todo esto la
clave de todo esto está precisamente en
los partidos minoritarios en los verdes
y los liberales y de hecho hoy los
liberales ya anunciaron su intención de
negociar primero con los verdes tratar
de limar asperezas ahí de buscar puntos
en común y de luego decidir ellos si les
conviene más con gobernar con los
socialdemócratas a la cabeza o con los
que conservadores a la cabeza pero hay
diferencias importantes aquí pues los
verdes preferirían gobernar con los
socialdemócratas mientras los liberales
preferirían gobernar con el bloque
conservador así que un camino muy largo
para alemania un camino muy difícil para
alemania y también bastante
incertidumbre para los alemanes tras las
elecciones de este domingo